-The protests sweeping
the country
have rocked
Donald Trump's presidency
and galvanized public opinion
in favor of a fundamental
rethinking of how policing works
in this country.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
As we've said before, there is
probably no worse person
on the face of the earth
to occupy the presidency
in this moment of national
crisis than Donald Trump.
We're in the middle
of a pandemic with a president
who doesn't understand
or care to understand science.
We're having an intense national
discussion on systemic racism,
and we elected a virulent racist
and serial golfer.
He's less ready to meet
the moment
than the dads on "Teen Mom."
Those guys are real duds.
He's a soulless business potato
whose brain has been zapped
by decades
of right-wing cable news
and the asbestos
in his buildings.
"Hold on one second, I'm gonna
take a bump of this wall candy."
[ Sniffs ]
Trump has always been
historically unpopular.
But now,
amid nationwide protests
against racist police brutality,
a deadly pandemic that
he utterly failed to contain,
and massive unemployment,
more Americans are coming around
to the idea that maybe,
just maybe, electing a racist,
Diet Coke-stained bean bag chair
wasn't the best idea.
Trump has sagged
considerably in polls
over the last few weeks.
To put it in photos,
he was here.
And now he's here.
Several polls have his approval
rating dipping below 40,
and tied with Joe Biden
in some very unlikely places.
-The new CNN national poll
shows Biden with a 14-point lead
over President Trump.
Our poll also shows
an overwhelming majority
of Americans support
the peaceful protests
and disapprove
of the president's response
to the unrest.
-The president's approval
rating slipped
seven points in the last month,
according to a new CNN poll.
And 63% of adults disapprove
of how he's handled
race relations in the country.
65% say his response
to the protest
has done more harm than good.
-The polls suggest Donald Trump
would be absolutely crushed
by Joseph Biden
if the election were held today.
Get this. In just the past week,
polls have come out
showing Biden up by 15 points
in Michigan, up 9 in Wisconsin,
up 4 in Arizona, up 2 in Ohio,
tied in Iowa, tied in Texas.
-And when a Democrat is ahead in
the polls against Donald Trump,
it's all over, baby!
And, who knows, Texas is
historically red,
but maybe Biden
has a chance there.
Sure, Skateboard Jones
didn't have
the best presidential campaign,
but he did come within two
and a half percentage points
of beating this were-badger.
The "Washington Post" poll
also found
that much of the opposition
to Trump is vehement,
as 47% of Americans say
they strongly disapprove
of the way the president
has responded to protests.
Wow, it's bad enough when
the majority disapprove of you,
but to have nearly half say
they strongly disapprove of you
must be depressing.
It's one thing if you pass
a note to a classmate that says,
"Do you like me?",
and they check "No."
It's another if they write in,
"I'd rather eat a burrito
filled with dog turds."
The polling is so bad for
Trump -- and this is true --
his campaign is running ads
on TV in Washington, D.C.
just so Trump
will see those ads
and feel better about himself.
"With their boss growing
increasingly agitated
with the state
of his re-election campaign,
and with the effort
of Republican critics
to undermine it,
President Trump's team
hatched a plan.
They'd run a series
of hard-hitting ads
and place them on networks
that they knew the president
and Congressional Republicans
would watch.
And so, over the past month,
the Trump campaign
has spent
slightly more than $400,000
on cable news ads
in the Washington, D.C. area,
buying time largely
on Fox News
but with some smaller buys
on CNN and MSNBC as well."
They spent nearly half a million
dollars on ads in a city
they know they won't win just so
the president will see them
and feel better about himself.
I mean, I guess --
I guess I get it.
Sometimes I leave the
Weather Channel on for my dog
so she doesn't get nervous
and chew up the sofa.
Just not sure if I'd do it
if it cost
half a million dollars.
Seriously, at this point,
I'd say they should just
sit him down
in front of "Sesame Street,"
but even Big Bird would take one
look at him and say,
"Hey, kid, maybe spelling's
not for you.
You want to try and find a stick
while the rest of us talk?
Yeah, go find a stick.
We're going to go do vowels.
You go find a stick."
So, Trump has seen his political
standing erode considerably.
And it's especially striking
to contrast Trump's numbers
with the overwhelming
public approval of the protests
spurred by the horrific murder
of George Floyd
at the hands of police.
Majorities of Americans
are finally coming around
to the reality that acts
of police violence
against black people
aren't just isolated incidents
from a few bad apples.
They're part of a
fundamentally corrupt system
based on a history of racism
and exploitation.
And that is a massive shift
in public opinion,
galvanized by
the nationwide protests.
And not only is public opinion
changing,
but so are the responses
from lawmakers.
In New York, for example,
activists have sought for years
to repeal a highly-restrictive
policy secrecy law
known as 50-A,
which shields police brutality
records from public view.
But yesterday,
thanks to the protests,
New York lawmakers repealed it.
"The law, known as 50-A,
exceeds virtually all in America
in the way
it blocks public requests
for more information
on problematic officers.
The controversial statute
technically keeps
the 'personnel records'
of police officers,
firefighters, and corrections
officers confidential
and not subject
to inspection or review."
I feel like they just
threw firefighters in there
to make it look better.
"Dave, I hear you squirted
your water
next to the fire
instead of onto it.
That's going in your file,
Dave."
This proves once again
that direct,
mass action in the streets
gets results.
The demonstrations are working.
Lawmakers are responding
to the pressure.
Even Republicans in Congress
are reportedly considering
a police reform bill.
It's a sign of just how far
the politics have shifted
that they're even talking
about it at all.
Senate Republicans spend
most of their time
rushing through unqualified
right-wing judges,
conducting absurd
investigations of Democrats,
and coming up with dumber
and dumber excuses
for why they're not commenting
on the new terrible thing
Trump has said.
"Oh, yeah, no, I'm sorry,
I didn't see it.
My wife, uh --
forgot to pay our Twitter bill?
Is that a thing?"
So, the politics of this issue
have shifted massively,
thanks to protesters
and organizers
in the streets,
doing the work.
People across the country
have also been shocked
and appalled by the countless
videos of police violence
against peaceful protesters
that have circulated online.
And there's a point at which
you have to ask yourself,
"Can this even be reformed?"
One bad flight
and you might be, like,
"Maybe we can make
air travel better."
But if every flight you take
ends up in the Hudson River,
you might think "It's time
to de-fund Spirit Airlines."
We've seen police officers
armed like they're going to war,
showing up in riot gear,
beating protesters,
shoving them to the ground,
hitting them with batons,
trapping them on bridges,
lobbing flash bangs
and pepper balls
and raining down tear gas
like they just turned
on the fog machine
at a 12-year-old's
roller rink party.
"Hey, guys, grab your skates
and get on the floor!
It's Adam's bar mitzvah!"
Bam-bam-ba-bam-ba!
I think that was maybe a mistake
to try to make that noise.
You know, if we were
in the studio,
that would be a sound effect.
But there you go.
That's how it went.
People are increasingly
asking themselves,
"Why are our tax dollars paying
for these egregious
abuses of power?"
Which is why you're increasingly
hearing a call from activists
to dismantle police departments
and de-fund the police,
a refrain that
has conservatives,
and many Democrats,
freaking out.
-The president tweeted
just a short time ago, quote,
"Law and order, not de-fund
and abolish the police.
The Radical Left Democrats
have gone crazy!"
-Dangerous offspring of
this movement is --
are you ready for this?
De-fund the police.
-This is a dangerous idea,
and it's an insane idea.
-Funding of police
is a local matter, as you know.
From the standpoint
of our legislation,
we're not going to that place.
-I don't support de-funding
the police.
-In the future, the left
envisions the only people
who will have guns
are people on their team.
And that's exactly what de-fund
the police really means.
It means a woke militia
policing our cities
enforcing Democratic Party
orthodoxy.
-Imagine what it's all going to
look like with no police at all.
De-fund the police?
You have no police department.
What are you going to do
to protect yourself
and your families?
-I don't know, Sean.
I just assumed you'd use
your sick MMA moves.
You guys know
Jean-Claude Van Ham.
Usually, MMA dudes look like
menacing fighting machines.
Hannity looks like
an out-of-shape dad
trying to impress his stepson.
"Tyler, come on out
to the garage,
I'm about to do
a roundhouse kick!
Oh! My groin, Tyler.
Buh!
Ooh, pulled it off the bone.
Get me an ice pack,
or just call the hospital."
Also, Tucker, you think the left
wants to replace
the police
with a "woke militia"?
In your warped mind,
what do you even imagine
this "woke militia"
would look like?
Antifa skate teens
patrolling the streets
in their "Hamilton" t-shirts,
forgiving everyone's
student loans
and forcing them to use their
free government healthcare?
"I'm sorry, sir, I have
no choice but to detain you
and bring you to the hospital
to get your rash
checked out, free of charge."
And then, jump on the back
of my board.
And then there's Trump,
who's clearly grasping
for just anything to revive
his sinking poll numbers,
and who seems to be road-testing
a bunch of different
attack lines all at once,
mainly by changing one word
and repeating himself.
-We won't be de-funding
our police.
We won't be dismantling
We won't be disbanding
our police.
We won't be ending
our police force.
-Ooh, someone got a thesaurus!
I guess Trump's had a lot
of free time in that bunker.
"Mr. President,
what are you doing down there?"
[ As Trump ] "I am...
defecating...
my dungarees."
And by the way, if you're
a Democratic politician
who finds the phrase
"de-fund the police"
somehow
politically inconvenient,
because it wasn't focus-grouped
into oblivion first
to ensure that it's as anodyne
and shaved-down
as possible, too bad.
It's not the job of activists
to make you feel
comfortable politically.
As Congresswoman
Alexandria Ocasio-Cortez put it,
"Poll-tested slogans
and electoral feasibility
is not the activists' job.
Their job is to organize support
and transform public opinion,
which they are doing.
Our job as policymakers is
to take the public's mandate,
and find and create pockets
to advance as much progress
as possible.
Progress takes a team
of different roles.
You don't criticize a pitcher
for not being a catcher."
Exactly!
You criticize a pitcher
for not pitching well.
Or, in the case of 50 Cent,
you criticize them for agreeing
to throw out a first pitch
without ever having thrown,
touched, seen, read,
or even heard about baseball
before in their entire life.
-And his first pitch
was not great.
Just a bit outside.
-We wanted to watch it again.
Just let us watch it again.
Instead of obsessively telling
activists and organizers
in the street
doing the work
how they can rewrite
their slogans
to make you feel
more safer politically,
maybe you can just listen
to them
when they explain
what they're calling for,
as Black Lives Matter
co-founder, Patrisse Cullors,
did on this show last week.
-If anybody has time,
they should look up
their city budget.
What we start to realize so much
in our communities
that are divested from,
that have little access
to health care,
educational opportunities,
access to jobs and healthy food,
is that our city governments
are using our tax dollars
to primarily pay
for an economy of punishment
over an economy of care.
And that's what so many
Black Lives Matter organizers
and organizers
that are allies
of Black Lives Matter
are asking for --
is to allow for a reallocation
of investment
into some of
the most marginalized
and divested-from
communities.
-Yes!
She's right.
For one thing, if you've ever
had the time
to look up your city's budget,
it's now.
You're probably
still in lockdown.
What else are you going to do?
Watch "The Sopranos" in your
sweatpants for the fourth time
while you bake your eighth loaf
of banana bread?
"Mmm, it's still --
still too dry."
Second, an economy of punishment
is the right way
to think about it.
For marginalized communities
and the black community
in particular,
we divest from the things
that help create a healthy,
safe, equitable society,
like housing and health care,
and we put that money
into surveillance
and punishment instead.
Just look at
the warped priorities
of New York City's budget.
"New York City spends more
on policing
than it does on the Departments
of Health, Homeless Services,
Housing Preservation
and Development,
and Youth and Community
Development combined."
Instead of spending all
that money on tanks
and riot gear
and pepper spray for police
so they can steal
people's bikes,
or arrest essential
delivery workers,
or slash people's tires,
or violently break up barbecues,
maybe we can shift that money
to any number of other areas
that actually help build
safe, healthy,
equitable communities --
like health care, housing,
mental health services,
or, hell, just pay people
to stand in Times Square
and tell tourists
where the M&Ms Store is
so the rest of us
don't have to.
You can't reform something
while continuing
to give it billions of dollars
to enact violence
on marginalized communities
with impunity.
Reforms are a good place
to start,
but our conception
of what policing is for,
and how much
policing we need,
is itself something we need
to fundamentally rethink,
which is why we're talking
about de-funding the police.
That doesn't mean murder
will suddenly become legal
and everyone will have
to take ninjutsu classes
from Cobra Hair Dye over here.
It just means taking money away
from a fundamentally
oppressive system,
undoing the overpolicing
and oversurveilling
of black communities,
and reallocating
many of the responsibilities
we currently assign
to police to other safer,
more effective alternatives
that don't involve someone
showing up to your door
with a badge and a gun.
-It's actually about
not having no police, right?
But making sure, again, that
communities have the resources
so that you can have less of
a footprint of police.
Right?
So I'll give you an example.
Lots of people have been
asking me
for the last couple of days,
"Hey,
if we de-fund the police, what
happens when you call 911?"
And what I say back is,
"Well, if something's on fire,
what number do you call?"
You call 911.
And who shows up?
It's the ambulance.
Or, sorry, it's the firetruck.
And if somebody's having
a heart attack, you call 911.
And the EMT shows up.
So we already have 911
giving lots of different
emergency services.
If the resources
that folks needed
so they didn't need to rely on
law enforcement
were there, all right?
If 911 had more options,
communities would feel safer,
and you wouldn't be introducing
a badge and a gun
to situations that law
enforcement can never be trained
to manage in the first place
and that they have been calling
to get out of the business
of for years.
That's what the majority
of protesters and activists
I talk to say that they want.
-Exactly.
Even a former police chief in
New Orleans and Nashville said,
"90% of all
the police department calls
that I've looked at in my life
have nothing to do
with a major Uniform Crime."
Let's spend the money we're
lavishing on police departments
on other nonviolent
alternatives,
like mental health resources
or substance abuse resources.
Or, if Tucker Carlson's
the one calling,
we can send the woke militia
to force-feed him,
I don't know, vegan sausage.
Maybe he'll like it.
Maybe that'll be
the end of it all.
Look, maybe we can just listen
to the activists
and the organizers
who are doing the work
instead of spending time
nitpicking their slogans.
But if you're looking
for synonyms
for de-funding the police,
President Thesaurus has,
like, plenty of ideas.
-De-funding our police,
dismantling our police,
disbanding our police,
ending our police force.
-This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
As New York struggles
to reopen this week,
remember that we're still
a city in crisis,
and City Harvest has been
stepping up
to meet the increased need.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the "donate" button.
Stay safe. Wash your hands.
We love you.